we have a voicemail number you can call
that number at any time of the day if
you get a hankering for some fried
chicken in the middle of the night and
you stumble over to the kitchen and you
say I'm gonna leave 12 voicemails for
the David Pakman show you can do that
and many people do you should see what
the mornings are like going through the
voicemails that came in we got a
voicemail very late in the evening last
night that is just a full-blown
conspiracy theorist who wants more
conspiracy talk on the David Pakman show
quite simply let's take a listen to it
hey talked a little bit about that rich
okay oh and the server's right later
yeah well it's gonna have to be much
much later because we don't we we we
aren't perpetuating the conspiracy
theories that Rudy Giuliani is going on
Fox News to try to perpetuate that
Donald Trump is tweeting about we don't
do you know let's have a big
conversation about issues like why do
the family members of politicians get
these highly paid lucrative gigs for
which they really only have access to
which they really only have access
because of their family members being in
positions of power that's a big picture
conversation I'm more than glad to have
him we can have it about Donald Trump's
family you know when when you ask the
question of hunter Biden would you be on
the board of burries ma if Joe Biden
weren't your dad the answer is no when
you ask Ivanka Trump would you be
sitting in for the Secretary of State if
Donald Trump weren't your dad the answer
is an even more resounding no and we can
have that conversation it is not what
Donald Trump's impeachment is about and
that's the important thing to remember
which hopefully is starting to get
through in some way shape or form we've
got a great bonus show planned for you
today the Grammys had a 12 year low
rating on Sunday I didn't even know the
Grammys were on Sunday I didn't see any
promos for the Grammys I didn't know
that
Grammy's were on Sunday I found out when
I read an article about the low ratings
that the Grammys were on Sunday I
believed that increasingly the era of
these awards shows has basically passed
now the right also doesn't like these
awards but for different reasons I don't
care about liberal actors saying liberal
things and award shows have at it and
then people can decide whether they want
to support your work or not but I have a
different view on it which we'll talk
about on the bonus show also are any of
you still eating romaine lettuce I think
I am getting off of romaine lettuce
based on a very good piece I read a
couple of days ago in The Boston Globe
which we will talk about in detail on
the bonus show and it's very ugly what's
going on with e.coli romaine lettuce now
responsible for more ecoli cases than
beef and beef was historically like the
source of e.coli I also want to talk
about Donald Trump's latest nugget of a
Middle East peace plan and does it
warrant praise does it warrant criticism
does it warrant a little bit of each
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
don't miss today's bonus show I'll be
joined by producer Pat Forde there
become a member at join pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show to get instant access
to the bonus show I will speak to you
then